i
wanted to ask you obviously we're at the
end of the year what's your um
who's your like what's your favorite
album of the year we're just talking
about the grammy nominations but what's
your personal
top album of 2020. top bottom of 2020 is
definitely no love lost by blast
that's fair that is that a ep that's i
don't know what that is but it's ep
we were just talking about blast in
there yeah yeah yeah so
what about this and by the way the way
he shot the videos yeah
crazy so the homie city james directed
that and he's
fine you go tap in with city james and
look at his videos
my god he's really like he's very very
yeah man
yeah so yeah so yeah if all right so if
we want to say blast
album is not an album so let's call that
a ep i already call that a ep
he's got the deluxe coming out which
will kind of fill it out go down
because i i'm drawing a blank here let
me see who well you're while you're
looking that up
let's go through the best hip-hop album
nominees and who you think
will win we got alfredo from freddie
gibbs and alchemist
uh we got royce's album d smoke black
habits
nazis king disease and
jay electronica i think either
uh freddie or nazis gonna win they might
give it nas might be the clear winner
you know what's funny is i said the same
thing i'm like
freddy should win but they might just
give it to knobs because never had a
grammy out of respect for their
culture so i would say one of the
biggest albums in hip we saying in
hip-hop
no no your favorite like album of the
year
i would say i would because i don't
really be listening albums like that but
if i'm gonna say i'm down listen i would
say uh
pop smoke the [ __ ] of the stars that was
a great that's a great album for me
it's a great album that i listened to
because i've been listening to like a
lot of
eps and [ __ ] like that like you do you
[ __ ] with uh keon bill you know
yeah of course his his little i think it
was uh after hours yeah he's dope he's
dope that was a great
he's got to put his shirt on though yeah
that guy never really
put a shirt on my guy but uh yeah so
yeah i think
those those projects really are
something that i listen to a lot
like on repeat especially like i was
saying like that blast project i'm glad
you said his name because i i didn't
know if it was zion or
yeah because because it's with the x is
in his name so yeah
i'm good i'm glad you now i know how to
say his name i don't know if he's trying
to do like you know how blast got like
the x in his
right maybe that's why he's doing it
because the x kind of looks like a k i
don't know i don't know i don't know why
he did that
i had to ask him like yo just because i
went to high school with him he went to
uh
we went to same heist yeah his project
is dope though yeah so a lot of hey look
there's like a lot of dope [ __ ] coming
out of la right now
yeah on the r b side yeah bro l.a kind
of kind of doing a damn thing bro
for real definitely no i agree i think
blast is uh
you know if we're talking about just
bodies of work eps albums it's up there
man
yeah man and i didn't know i was looking
at the credits the other day bro he's
producing all that himself yeah i was
he was up here for the podcast and he's
like russ he records himself
mixes and produces and masters and like
he does everything himself
yeah it's crazy yeah i i record mix
and master all my stuff but i don't
produce the beats like that's making
this
next level like we start producing your
[ __ ] well you know the kaelin record
the the the pull-up and get right with
it he produced that wow
so that that he that's his beat over
that kalin record yeah
that's crazy super crazy shout out to
blast man yeah but he moved you got
music with blast
yeah we got a we got like a song we hit
that i don't know
hit boy yeah hit produced it me him and
hit that sounds like a big move man
that sounds like a big move for the city
if hit clear that [ __ ]
it clear that [ __ ] so that'd be some
dope [ __ ] that'd be some dope [ __ ]
that's a record we did like a year maybe
a year and a half ago
yeah and that's before you know blast
was blast yeah he had literally just put
up off the strength like yo bro i [ __ ]
with your [ __ ] let's work you know what
i'm saying i ain't even tapped in with
him i'm like bro
fly young man do your thing you know i
don't want to be the guy that like yo
remember this
this record we got you know i don't want
to do that bro fly spread your wings my
guy
cause i'm rooting for you for sure yeah
that pop smoke album though they did a
great job with it man i thought that uh
you know it's hard to pull off an album
when someone's not here anymore
especially kind of knowing that probably
a lot of those songs weren't finished
mm-hmm they did a masterful job yeah
yeah
yeah i wanted i was wondering how they
pulled off certain things and and i
don't know how much
how much 50 had his hands in it but that
was it was it was dope because he had a
couple of great records on there
oh yeah solid body of work yeah
shout out to pop smoke